what's going on billy you got a cough
are you sick
are you sick i also had covet already
nobody knows that but [ __ ] that [ __ ]
dude how bad was it when you got call of
duty
it was bad it was bad i mean i i wasn't
i didn't die and i wasn't gonna die but
that does not take away from
how miserable it was i mean it was
terrible i
i still have side effects i mean i was i
was sick for like
two like two months almost oh jesus and
this was in um august august like a
couple months ago
oh so this was even after you were
vaccinated yeah but i want it to be
clear that it's it's it is because of
the vaccine that i'm fine because if i
i think if i weren't
if i weren't vaccinated i would have
like died because it was bad i mean but
it was it was just
okay when i say it was bad
i mean more just mean that it felt
horrible but really in the scheme of of
covid it was not bad like you know what
i mean when you're sick it feels [ __ ]
horrible when you have a cold you know i
have a cold right now when when you have
you know the flu it feels like you're
dying
right you're okay you know so so when i
say it's bad it's not like oh my god i
was gonna die of covida and the vaccine
doesn't work the vaccine's [ __ ]
amazing and it also saved phineas from
getting it saved my parents from getting
it saved my friends from getting it